hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Gotham tall maker Red Hood video I
would say this episode is about is comic
book II as you could possibly get next
to last week's episode so what I'm gonna
do is I'm just gonna start with an
explainer for the characters that we saw
in the episode the Red Hood gang and the
dollmaker well we kind of didn't see the
dollmaker but I'll explain into the
version that Gotham is doing of all
these characters is an adaptation so
it's not right out of the comics it's
just like aspects of a bunch of
different versions of these characters
it's the same deal as it is with like
the reverse flash on the flash TV show
it's it's not like straight out of the
comics it's blending elements from all
eras of the comics so just careful for
spoilers from the episode if you haven't
seen it yet but starting with the Red
Hood gang so the Red Hood gang is kind
of a weird story the version that most
people know about is the version that
Alan Moore created in The Killing Joke
that it's a famous joke or storyline The
Joker is a failed comedian who agrees to
help out a gang ends up wearing the Red
Hood and then ultimately becomes the
Joker so in that version of the story
the leader of the Red Hood gang becomes
the Joker here's the twist though Alan
Moore was actually writing a revision of
the Red Hood character that was created
in 1951 in Detective Comics 168 that was
the first time a Red Hood character
appeared so Alan Moore didn't originate
the Red Hood character but he did create
the Red Hood gang as we know it today
just add to that the original Red Hood
character became the Red Hood was
inspired to put the Red Hood on because
of the Wayne's murderer so Bruce Wayne's
parents died it inspires the Red Hood to
become the Red Hood and then everything
gets kind of met after that anybody
who's read the new 52 is totally not
surprised with comics revising
backstories so during the new 52 comics
they revised the Joker's origin story
and the dollmaker became the person who
created his modern face he was already
the Joker he was inside Arkham Asylum
and the doll maker came in and they kind
of rebooted his character so to speak a
rebirth of the Joker that was Detective
Comics vol 2 number 1 so we have a doll
maker in the episode we have Red Hood
gang there's a whole lot of meta
crossover going on now the doll maker is
a different story so this is also a
different version than we've seen in the
comics the version that Gotham is doing
is called francis dulmacher
he's a european and he was mentioned in
the Selina Kyle episode
beginning of the season he was the one
that was rounding up children as part of
that kidnapping ring and shipping them
overseas we've also seen a version of
doll maker on arrow during season two
they did the Barton Mathis doll maker
which is a little closer to the comics
so Gotham's version the francis
dulmacher character has never appeared
in the comics but I expect them to
incorporate a lot of Easter eggs so
hopefully that explains things a little
bit but it doesn't mean that that
character at the end of the episode that
put the red hood on is gonna become the
Joker because these are all origin
stories Gotham as the TV show could
choose the ticket in any direction they
want so presumably we'll find out in the
next like three or four seasons or
however many seasons it gets another
week on Gotham another Joker origin
story
it wouldn't be Gotham if they weren't
telling like a bunch of different
versions of the Joker origin story I
think I mentioned it in the last week's
video but there are like a ton of
different versions of Joker origin
stories like he has no one set origin
story that DC has said this is the
official one I try not to take the TV
show too seriously so I don't get really
upset that they're trying to put this
Jerome character out as the Joker
character he was actually listed on the
IMDB for this episode so I thought that
he was going to be the one to take the
red hood at the end of the episode they
might have changed that at the last
minute but IMDB is always wrong so don't
always go based on what you see on IMDB
that would have been totally crazy
though Gordon would have taken the hood
back to the station and it would've
ended up in Jerome's hands that would
have been more of a comic book moment so
here we go getting into top five moments
in the episode starting with number five
witnessed the birth of the Red Hood the
really cool thing that I appreciated is
that that they just had the Red Hood
passed through a lot of hands in the
episode first it starts off it is an
offhanded thing like someone's like I'm
gonna wear a mask it's gonna be a symbol
I'm gonna have some fun with it be a
little bit of a Robin Hood then the next
guy who takes it from him is like okay
sure I'll play along with this each of
them have very different motives they
didn't even crazier person takes it at
the end and it all goes to [ __ ] till
finally we see a random kid off the
street pick it up just a lot more joke
or teasers but but it's a nice twist on
the Batman mythos anybody who wears the
cow can be a symbol so anybody that
wears this red hood will also be a
symbol and obviously in a very negative
context some of the dialogue that they
gave to some of these crazier characters
did make it sound like they were trying
to make them sound kind of like the
Joker just being really clip but then
BAM theory down BAM theory down they
killed so many Joker theories in this
episode of
moving on to number four meet Alfred's
old war comrade Reggie bane
you can always kind of tell when things
are going dark when Alfred gets really
upset in the character that they cast he
was really rough around the edges
clearly an alcoholic living as a
homeless person looks like he was hired
by the Wayne board just because they saw
he was on hard times had a connection to
the Wayne's all to get rid of Bruce so
they can control Wayne Enterprises
beyond some of the greater gears that
were turning in the episode with this
this overarching plot it was just fun to
watch him punch it out with Bruce I
guess Alfred isn't a big fan of krav
maga it's really hard to say how dark
they're gonna take this David Mizzou's
Bruce Wayne character in terms of
different actors to play the Bruce Wayne
character Bruce Wayne Batman character
I'm sure it's fairly divisive everyone
has their own opinion on who's the
darkest I still think that Michael
Keaton's Batman is darker than Christian
Bale's Batman all things being equal I
think that he was just a little more
cynical just because he was an older
character than the Christian Bale Batman
it's like each time they reboot the
series they aged Batman down just like a
little bit until you get kid Batman here
so kid Batman learning to draw some
blood moving on to number 3 The
Adventures of Butch and penguin this is
a really nice completely unrelated
storyline in the episode Butch in
penguin trying to get more booze it's
really hard to tell what's going on with
butch just because of the way the actor
is playing it it's like you can't tell
if he's pulling a fast one on the
penguin like if his programming is gonna
refer zazz is programming I don't expect
any sudden twist in that storyline to
happen until fish Mooney re-emerges
inside Gotham and right now she seems
like she's tied up in this dollmaker
storyline but everyone raise a glass to
not being a sidekick anymore I would say
my funniest butch moment in the episode
was when he did like the Batman appear
out of nowhere and scared the [ __ ] out
of penguin in the car moving on to
number two the Wayne board is trying to
kill Bruce Wayne this seems pretty
straightforward they want money in
control they want Arkham City they they
want the control that that's gonna bring
over Gotham and the added wealth so
they're trying to get rid of Bruce so
that he won't stop them I don't
necessarily think the show is gonna do
straight up court of owls but I think
that they're seeding that I think this
is an Easter Egg for that super-rich
clandestine organization that seemingly
makes decisions by consensus so if you
haven't read the court of owls storyline
from the comics it's it's one of the
better ones so totally check it out it
involves a really interesting twist on
the the Bruce Wayne origin story the
Bruce Wayne not Batman or
story but I don't think the show is
gonna go there I don't expect Thomas
Wayne or any of that stuff if you guys
have read the comics and my number one
totally WTF moment fish Mooney jabs her
own I out who saw that coming
this is gonna be crazy I would say of
all the body parts that you could lose
on a TV show and I is the easiest just
because they could put an eyepatch on
and they don't have to digitally remove
it every week and how cool is that the
Jeffrey Combs is the doll makers creepy
office manager it totally fits that the
re-animator is part of the dollmaker
mythos hunka theme if you've never seen
Jeffrey Combs stuff before he played way
youn on Deep Space 9 for a long time is
this really creepy villain he plays a
lot of characters like that really
creepy antagonists so he fits perfectly
with the tone of the show I would say of
all the running plots the fish Mooney
one is is the one that feels like it's
most gone off the rails crazy no idea
where they're taking this but I I think
they want to shock people and keep the
character interesting here's my big
question for you guys just thinking
about this fish Mooney WTF stuff do you
feel like it's just a twist of the show
trying to keep her interesting like an
act of bad faith or are you really
excited to see like where they're gonna
take this dollmaker storyline I mean do
you think it's really awesome I'm kind
of 50/50 on it right now I'm not a big
fan of the fish Mooney character but I
do like them taking a big chance like
this it feels kind of like they're
shooting fish in a barrel
so to speak you know quote-unquote haha
make as many jokes as you want it's like
on the list of WTF things you can do in
an episode to make people freaked out
it's you know one you kill character two
you maim them in a big way or three you
have like some big reveal that they're
really secretly someone else I'm just
gonna go ahead and completely ignore the
Barbara storyline totally not digging
where that's going I feel like they
could either turn that character into
Harley Quinn she could either go
completely crazy she's already halfway
there or they could do like a like a
Barbara Gordon Batgirl storyline and
that would actually make me a little
upset I feel like the character is too
far away from being able to be that kind
of hero in order for a character to put
a mask on they have to go through a
crucible and that usually takes multiple
seasons so I don't think that she's
gonna become like a Batgirl type
character of a vigilante type character
I think it's more likely that she would
go completely nuts at least I think that
would be more fun to watch doesn't it
just look though bait based on that
wardrobe that she pulled out that she
Shops at the same store as Tim Burton
for all his Batman films I really do
like the way that they blend visual
elements from all the Batman films
speaking of which there was actually a
nice Easter Egg for the classic Batman
movie the 1966 movie whenever Bruce
pulls the wine out and Alfred's like a
burgundy 1966 one of your father's
favorites 1966 was just the year that
the classic Batman movie came out if you
guys saw any other Easter eggs that I
haven't mentioned yet just write them
below in the comments but like I said
big ones dollmaker Joker origin story
Red Hood gang those are those are the
real big ones kind of quarter aloes
quarter valise maybe maybe Easter Egg so
here's what's going on with the rest of
the DC Comics TV shows for the rest of
the weeks so arrows going to Nanda
Parbat it's gonna be a big racial ghouls
storyline be sure to subscribe to get
that video that's gonna be in a
Wednesday there's no new episode of the
flash tonight so I'm just gonna do a
bonus video for that what's gonna happen
after this week though is that the flash
and arrow will both be on break till
March 17th and 18th you know that
Tuesday and Wednesday at that same week
so while those shows are on break I'll
just be doing bonus videos for them
Gotham is just gonna keep going though
there'll be another new episode next
week I believe Gotham has 22 episodes
total so that's 5 more new episodes
arrow and the flash both have 23
episodes in the season so there'll be
plenty more new episodes spilling over
into Game of Thrones territory there'll
be a lot of awesome stuff going on at
the same time in a couple weeks I'm
actually I'm really excited so while you
guys wait for non Depar bad on arrow and
my flash bonus video you can click here
for last week's Gotham video a little
more of a straight-up Joker storyline
and you can click here to get ready for
arrow thank you so much for watching so
let's all high-five I'll see you guys
tonight
you